whatever they do I never wanted the
internet in our [ __ ] business but
when you tweet you was faking it all
along and putting people in the mix and
playing up a narrative you know people
think about me no you feel like so you
feel like he started it on the internet
when we broke up yes okay okay tell me
tell me about that because when I think
of I like your your social media
influencer I just assumed you were first
no but that's why I'm saying nobody
really looks at the facts and really
what unfolded so when we broke up he had
tweeted you were faking it all along and
he said that they were lyrics from a
song
but thousands he got thousands of
retweets and then I became the big bad
gold digging [ __ ] who just used him and
had a baby and bounced on him and then I
became this pedophile
psycho [ __ ] that is just vindictive and
he started it you put the internet in
our business I literally just had a baby
my stitches in my vagina were just
healing why would I want to go to the
internet and have it be some [ __ ]
spectacle for everybody to see
that we broke up why would I want that
like after all the stuff I've learned
even then that doesn't even make it's
not logical and now we have a child my
child has his name
so what do I gain from going back and
forth my baby daddy my son has his name
so why would I want to make him look
stupid and have people in our [ __ ] so
what did you do after the Tweet did you
come and like defend yourself or what no
and that's because I was silent because
that's when all the videos came out yes
so that's what happened because when all
like I'm telling you I've been through
some different things giving birth
how I felt after I don't know it was
just like a crash like hormonally I
don't
I was going through all this stuff and
you just feel like for me I just felt
like I was like just wanted to die right
and
when he said that I was like delete the
[ __ ] tweet you know I can't have
deleting it but the damage already been
done all the blogs picked it up all
these stories started circulating
and
I did not tell my story because quite
frankly nobody gives a [ __ ] nobody cares
that I was cheated on nobody cares what
I went through when I was pregnant
nobody [ __ ] cares
so what do I look like going on live
crying about my baby daddy about a
decision I made ultimately right this is
why I picked to be my child's father I
don't need your [ __ ] sympathy and I
don't need your [ __ ] empathy you're
not going to understand even if I even
just this interview right here he may
have a better idea but you're still
gonna think what you want to think about
me so I for months I was silent but you
know what I did
I lean into being a villain okay what
you guys think I'm a piece of [ __ ] you
think I'm a monster well I'm gonna show
you what a monster really is so then I'm
on Jackson State's campus taking selfies
hide your sons and because you guys are
already saying that in my comments
so instead of crying that's kind of
funny no it was funny it was it was
hilarious I loved it you know so I'm
like let me just laugh at My Pain just
like with you like when people say mean
stuff about you okay this is what it is
this is how I feel you're not going to
use this and hurt me and that is
probably something like so you're almost
like sometimes you're you're trolling
the comments oh yeah absolutely but
people don't know my personality people
think either you're being serious yes
because they don't because they don't
know my humor they don't know my
personality they don't actually even
know how I cope and I have been on
social media since July of 2012. I have
seen Instagram in its many phases before
there was even videos on there right
I don't know another way
because if you read [ __ ] and you obsess
about it you're crying in the car right
it's I feel like kind of a guinea pig
because I'm one of like the original
Instagram girls right
so
I just feel like I don't like to explain
myself to strangers now me and you are
talking where I want you to understand
you're asking me a question I'm telling
you the truth right but to a bunch of
strangers who have no desire to listen
to me as you are I'm not explaining
myself go hide your sons I don't care
you already think I'm this anyways I
can't convince you otherwise and again
I'm not Jehovah's Witness I don't
convert people you ain't a Believer I
ain't here to convert you so yeah a lot
of it is like my personality people
don't really know how I am now now
moving forward I don't really like to
troll as much because I realize how
damaging being something I'm not a
villain how damaging it has been because
that's not my truth like you've seen me
I'm really just a little sweetie pie
that's just kind of how I am I don't
like people to see me vulnerable and
nice and she's actually likable because
I would at one point I would have rather
people fear me
think I'm a succubus evil [ __ ]
because I I didn't want people to see
this mushy part because it's disgusting
right and that's I've always judged that
part but I've told myself I'm gonna
authentically be myself
if it's not as exciting as being a
villain right if I don't get as many
clicks if I don't get any more followers
moving forward today at least I can say
I'm being myself because all that [ __ ]
show that wasn't me being myself that
was me playing into a character that is
like not even a fraction like five
percent of who I am
what do you think about the phrase life
is about choices and trade-offs I agree
I mean I love Kevin Samuels I feel like
that was definitely a message like that
he would preach a lot
and it's true
what did you what was it like meeting
Kevin
and he's much taller in person and did
you take any of his advice second part
I felt like I started to think about my
life and what I wanted to do moving
forward which kind of I don't say it's
scary I don't want to judge it but like
he talked about a lot of uncomfortable
truths about the perception of men and
like family structure and my situation
and
um it was a lot of difficult truths that
were really hard to hear and I feel like
I started thinking more of a having more
of a business mentality after I spoke to
Kevin and I think he's was very kind I
listened to him a lot when I was
pregnant and I felt like his message
often went missed because they would
sensationalize
um him being hard on women I've heard
him be hard on men I've heard both you
know but the internet's gonna run with
what's the most viral but no I I loved
meeting him he was a fellow Pisces like
myself he was very Charming he's very
funny very open-minded but he he was
tough he was just like tough love so
yeah I miss him you know yeah that's the
one
that's the one and I as I've told you
this but I really wish I could have
interviewed him or like had him on my
show like that's the one person that I I
just used to watch it's like you watched
him so much he felt like you knew him
absolutely and I'd only talk to him I
think I talked to him twice like once
about my channel and once about an ex
like boyfriend of mine and it was like I
don't know you just like felt like you
knew him even though like I'd only
talked to him twice really yeah and I
think people underestimated how much he
really cared he put a lot of time energy
and effort into talking about family
structures and talk and having people be
accountable and calling out the the I
have a PhD you know die with a dog like
he called out a lot of things that are
gonna be people's realities if they
don't look at their lives now so I think
that's why a lot of his content was rub
people the wrong way my perspective you
know everyone has their own feelings but
because he's necessary he was about
outcomes not really what felt good yep
and a lot of people would like I hate it
when people would like question his
intentions or like you know what I'm
saying like when I'm just like who cares
his outcomes are good he has people
making videos about as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible